مشاعر وملامح الفرح تغمر المكان هنا في
ميدان النصر بوسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
ولليوم الثاني على التوالي بعد اعلان دخول
القوات المسلحه الاخرانيه الى مدينه خرسون
واستعاده السيطره عليها
[موسيقى]
حتى تجمع العشرات من المواطنين النازحين
من مدينه خرسون وقراها التي وقعت تحت
السيطره الروسيه منذ الايام الاولى للحرب
ولمده تسعه اشهر ليعبر عن فرحتهم ورغبتهم
في العوده لمعانقه مراتح الصبا وذكريات
الطفوله للعلم ان تقول هناك في وقت
الاحتلال كلمه شكرا بالاكرانيا هذه جريمه
الوضع كان صعبا هناك حتى غدرنا
وارغب بشده في العوده ورؤيه الجميع
والمجد للقوات المسلحه التي استطاعت ان
تفعل ذلك
انا من الضفه اليسرى للاسف ما زالت محتله
ولكن مشاعري سعاده ودموع لاننا انتظرنا
ذلك طويلا وهذا كان صعبا لقد نلنا ذلك
بالدم ونحن نؤمن ونعلم وننتظر كامل
التحرير وسننتظر مهما طال الانتظار فخرسون
مدينه اوكرانيه
ويمجدون قواتهم المسلحه التي جعل ذلك
ممكنا ويقولون انهم لن ينسوا من ضحوا
بانفسهم لاستعاده اراضيهم وحياتهم التي
فقدوها حول اضطر الى النزوع لقناتي
العربيه والحدث حذيفه